most of what we do early on when we
first learn about calculus is to use
limits we use limits to figure out
derivatives of functions to figure out
derivatives of functions in fact the
definition of a derivative uses the
notion of a limit it's the it's a slope
around the point as we take the limit of
points closer and closer to the point in
question and you've seen that many many
many times over in this video we're
going to do I guess we're going to do it
in the opposite direction we're going to
use derivatives we're going to use
derivatives to figure out limits to
figure out limits and in particular
limits that end up an indeterminate form
and when I say by indeterminate form I
mean that when we just take the limit as
it is we end up with something like 0
over 0 or infinity over infinity or
negative infinity over infinity or maybe
negative infinity over negative infinity
or positive infinity over negative
infinity all of these are in determined
indeterminate undefined forms and to do
that we're going to use l'hopital's rule
lop petals rule lop it hulls lop it
hulls rule and in this video I'm just
going to show you what lah petals rule
says and how to apply it because it's
fairly straightforward and it's a it's
actually a very useful tool sometimes if
you're in some type of a math
competition they ask you to find a hard
a limit that when you just plug the
numbers in you get something like this
lava tiles rule is normally what they
are testing you for and in a future
video I might approve it but that gets a
little bit more involved the application
is actually reasonably straightforward
so what lava tiles rule tells us that if
we have that if we have and I'll do it
an abstract firm form first but I think
when I show you the example it will all
be made clear that if the limit if the
limit as X approaches C of f of X is
equal to 0 which is also so if this is
equal to 0 and and the limit as X
Roach's C of G of X is equal to zero and
and this is another hand and the limit
the limit as X approaches C of f prime
of x over G prime of X exists and it
equals L then so all of these conditions
have to be met this is the inter
indeterminate form of 0 over 0 so this
is the first case then then we can say
that the limit as X approaches C of f of
X over G of X is also going to be equal
to L so this might seem a little bit
bizarre to you right now and I'm
actually going to write the other case
and then I'll do an example we'll do
multiple examples of the examples we're
going to make it all clear so this is
the first case and the example we're
going to do is actually going to be a of
this case now the other case is if the
limit the limit as X approaches C of f
of X is equal to positive negative
positive or negative infinity and and
the limit as X approaches C of G of X is
equal to positive or negative infinity
and and the limit of I guess you could
say the quotient of the derivatives
exists and the limit as X approaches C
of f prime of X over G prime of X is
equal to L then we can make this same
statement again then we can make this
exact statement let me just copy that
out then this again edit copy and then
let me paste it so either of these two
situations and then just to kind of make
sure you understand what you're looking
at this is the situation where if you
just try to evaluate this limit right
here you're going to get F of C which is
0 or the limit as X approaches C of f of
X over the limit as X approaches C of G
of X
that's going to give you zero over zero
and so you say hey I don't know what
that limit is but this says well look if
this limit exists I could take the
derivative of each of these functions
and then try to evaluate that limit and
if I get a number if that exists then
they're going to be the same limit this
is the situation where when we take the
limit we get infinity over infinity or
negative infinity or positive infinity
over positive or negative infinity so
these are the two indeterminate forms
and to make it all clear let me just
show you an example because I think this
will make things a lot more a lot more
clear so let's say we are trying to find
let's say we are trying to find the
limit lose in a new color let me do it
in this purplish color let's say we
wanted to find the limit as X approaches
zero of sine of X over X now if we just
view this if we just try to evaluate it
at 0 or take the limit as we approach 0
in each of these functions we're going
to get something that looks like 0 over
0 sine of 0 is 0 or the limit as X
approaches 0 of sine of X is 0 and
obviously as X approaches 0 of X that's
also going to be 0 so this is our
indeterminate form and if you want to
think about it this is our f of X that f
of X right there is a sine of X and our
G of X this G of X right there for this
first case is is the X right
G of X is equal to X and f of X is equal
to sine of X and notice well we
definitely know that this meets the
first two constraints the limit as X and
in this case C is 0 the limit as X
approaches 0 of sine of X is 0 and the
limit as X approaches 0 of X is also
equal to 0 so we get our indeterminate
form so let's see at least whether this
limit even exists if we take the
derivative of f of X and we put that
over the derivative of G of X and take
that the limit as X approaches 0 in this
case X approaches 0 that's our C let's
see if this limit exists
so I'll do that in the blue so let me
take so let me write the derivatives of
the two functions so f prime of X if f
of X is sine of X what's F prime of X
well it's just cosine of X we've learned
that many times and if G of X is X what
is G prime of X that's super easy the
derivative of X is just 1 so let's see
let's try to take the limit let's try to
take the limit as X approaches 0 of f
prime of x over G prime of X over their
derivatives so that's going to be the
limit as X approaches 0 of cosine of x
over over 1 and this then I wrote that
one little strange over 1 and this is
pretty straightforward what is this
going to be well as X approaches 0 of
cosine of X that's going to be equal to
1 that's equal to 1 and obviously the
limit as X approaches 0 of 1 that's also
going to be equal to 1 so in this
situation we just saw that the limit the
limit as X approaches RC in this case is
0 as X approaches 0 of f prime of X over
G prime of X is equal to 1 this limit
exists and it equals 1 so we've met all
of the conditions this is the case we're
dealing with limit as X approaches 0 of
sine of X is equal to 0 limit as X
approaches 0 of X is also equal to 0 the
limit of the derivative of sine of X
over the derivative of X which is cosine
of X over 1 we found this to be equal to
1 so all of these the all of these
kotappa conditions are met so then we
know this must be the case that the
limit as X approaches 0 of sine of X
over X must be equal to 1 it must be the
same it must be the same limit as this
value right here where we take the
derivative of the f of X and of the G of
X I'll do more examples in the next few
videos and I think it'll make it a lot
more concrete